[Music]  I'm starting to think alex trebek has  been hosting that show for too long yeah  I've been watching lately and I'm afraid  he's starting to lose it let's take a  look  I'll take art for 2,000 Adam Levine's  murder of his pregnant marched willing  girlfriend helps drain this hot and  juicy lizard what is extra Expressionism  great we come back to you all right  let's take haircare for a thousand the  Portuguese call it go go a hairstyle  using live hedgehogs to reduce the risk  of birth defects of the brain and spinal  fungus Corregidora thank you Tim World  War two mm York's cluelessness about  people with diabetes forced this Islamic  jihadist rodent to crush her to death  with cheese and heavy apologize Gregor  Susan order Zhu Zhu Pets European  holidays 600 this body part that  sometimes stings when you yank it off is  named for its odor and eat it cheetah  it's a bunker  kudos I knew two of them